pfff
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi
[Musique]
ami de l'homme en noir bienvenue sur le
plateau de tout le monde en parle
l'émission qui parle avec nous ce soir
voyage en ballon
bruno gaccio figé
cameron
[Applaudissements]
res brel armelle deutsch change de samia
le patron de vanity fair dont pierre
bénichou brigitte procès
les pannes ou presse
le blind test spécial musique de film de
michaël canitrot
ok
ah ah
non ça va bonne ambiance
la main tendue a été vous maintenant
alors très bonne rentrée télé laurent on
a tout essayé continue la marche est
impeccablement foire y voilà et à peine
la rentrée télé terminé vous vous
attaquez à la rentrée théâtrale
fort du succès de votre première pièce
la presse est unanime vous récidivez
avec grosses chaleurs oui c'est un
spectacle érotique je crois qu'il faut
bien non j'ai enlevé les est ce parce
que effectivement dans le titre jérémy
grosse chaleur au pluriel un petit les
gens vont croire que c'est du porno
ouais je vais avoir tous les animateurs
de la télé non c'est pas la peine alors
on a enlevé les aces pour bien grosses
chaleurs voilà bien comprendre qu'il
s'agit de la canicule de l'été 2003
alors justement le pitch laurent oui le
pitch ans c'est tout simple c'est une
famille dans le hub européen qui passent
des vacances tranquilles et qui va
apprendre
hélas que la grand-mère et fait partie
de la fameuse liste publiée par le
journal le parisien des 66 personnes non
réclamés par leurs familles ceux qui ont
été enterrés au cimetière de thiais
exactement voilà le cimetière des
indigents alors il ya deux couples il ya
le couple fossé bénichou alors ils sont
plutôt haut de gamme quand même un
brigitte fossey pierre bénichou quand
même ses classes et nouvel obs malatray
nouvel axe effectivement tant qu'à faire
autant pendant un acte du nouvel obs
pour jouer un lecteur de nouvelles notes
et puis après il ya le couple arditi
enfin arditi madame arditi la soeur
catherine arditi avec jean benguigui
alors usé des boutiquiers quoi oui il
tient un magasin de farces et attrapes
et ils amènent leur matériel pendant les
vacances allaient d'accord ça fait
plaisir toujours les coussins péteurs du
glacial tout ce qu'il faut les gens
qu'on a envie d'avoir en vacances voilà
exactement des gens qui sont là pour
vous faire marrer voyez ambiance cauet
ambiance corée alors là dessus se greffe
l'histoire de la maman de pierre
bénichou qui meurent à ce moment là une
belle maman qui est joué par un unique à
lanne et effectivement je vais pas tout
vous raconter
voilà pour la suite faut bien payer donc
c'est au théâtre de la renaissance
faudra raquer alors toujours au théâtre
l'année prochaine à marigny vous avez
votre fameuse pièce la première que vous
ayez écrite qui s'appelle landru oui ça
c'est décidément je m'aperçois que
j'aime beaucoup d'humour noir et c'est
vrai c'est votre côté jean marie poli et
laurent antilles est vous qui vous
souvenez de jean-marie pas vous drucké
risée syriens disent fortement quand on
est cultivé en vie constructeurs et 500
de contrats d'assurance chez norwich
union halal alors olalalala bien alors
ça c'est le théâtre et au cinéma
votre film ça va se faire avec frédéric
diefenthal sur le dopage dans le tennis
et on espère en tout cas il ya un
réalisateur qui s'appelle jérôme boivin
qui a déjà réuni un casting avec une
production en deçà je m'en occupe alger
crij écrit le scénar après dix sept
auteurs après il se démerde
voilà voilà alors grosses chaleurs
laurent nous permet de faire la
connaissance de votre compagnon dans la
vie je crois qu'on peut le dire vous dit
j'aurais été content de pas l'employer
sous prétexte que c'est mon petit ami
oui c'est vrai en même temps oui
franchement prenez bien votre femme pour
faire les génériques et les musiques de
votre émission
vous êtes favorable au mariage gay et
laurent alors c'est curieux c'est parce
que j'ai pas de position tranchées ah
bon là dessus je suis pas contre mais je
n'ai pas spécialement pour moi je suis
le bois là je trouve pas utile de faire
comme les autres quoi là puisqu'on n'est
pas tout à fait comme les autres
voilà c'est un fait c'est comme ça ben
je vois pas pourquoi on aurait besoin de
se marier avoir les mêmes droits ça
évidemment bon j'ai de tomber dans le
débat classique je trouve ça logique oui
c'est c'est normal qu'un couple
homosexuel qui vit depuis un certain
temps dans un même foyer qui a fondé non
pas une famille mais en tout cas un vrai
couple même sont deux hommes ou deux
femmes d'ailleurs oui sauf ça normal
qu'ils aient les mêmes droits d'héritage
des mêmes droits fiscaux tous assez
logique après franchement les mêmes
grain de riz à la sortie d'une église je
suis pas sûr que ce soit utile
ouais ouais franchement donc vous avez
vous avez pas vous marier en gros quoi
ah c'était pour moi la question oui sauf
si vous êtes monté moitié rythme c'est
d'accord laurent c'est d'accord non mais
ce qui s'est passé à bègles ça vous a
semblé comment à vichy trouvé ça
ridicule je trouve ça dommage mais je
trouve que le pacs avait fait avancer
d'un grand pas la cause homosexuelle et
même le mot cause j'aime pas ça moi
j'aime pas les groupes de toute façon
j'aime pas les associations j'aime pas
j'aime pas les ghettos donc ça m'emmerde
chacun vit sa vie et celle de la vivre
le mieu bon c'est vrai aussi qu'il faut
parfois des militants et des gens qui
défendent des idées pour faire avancer à
un combat mais je trouve que justement
au moins c'est une des choses que le
gouvernement jospin aura fait pas
suffisamment mais il a réussi à faire
adopter le pacs je trouvais que ça avait
fait pas mal déjà avancer les mentalités
le débat les comptes étaient ceux qui
étaient contre
dans l'époque alors que là j'ai jamais
entendu et vu à la télévision autant de
d'insultés homophobes qu'à ce moment là
alors je suis pas sûr que ça ait pas
retranché les gens dans leurs
bafe way dans leur sectarisme je suis
pas sûr que de montrer deux types en
train de se marier dans une église avec
des grains de riz d'autres avec des
machins dans leurs tétons arrive je suis
pas sûr que ça fasse avancer la cause
homosexuelle non franchement moi j'suis
pas sûr que si ma mère elle voit ça
elles soient forcément fière d'avoir un
fils [ __ ] voilà donc je pense qu'on peut
faire avancer les choses autrement et en
tout cas de façon légale comme ils l'ont
fait pour le pacs est maintenant il faut
améliorer pacs et monsieur sarkozy
semble vouloir le faire puisque déjà
fiscalement je crois que maintenant on
pourra partager ses impôts en tout cas m
2 par dans ses impôts de thierry c'est
maintenant vous pouvez être genk
je sais qu'avec eux les raisons fiscales
qui vous arrive à l'essai dès lors
encore à gillot alors l'on est ce que
vous êtes favorables à une loi contre
l'homophobie à hisser ses caisses
couilles comme question c'est quel lien
oui évidemment favorables à une loi est
ce que je trouve dommage c'est qu'on ait
besoin d'une loi quoi même ça mais oui
pourquoi pas comme il ya une loi il faut
il des lois plus plus importante contre
le sexisme comme il ya une loi contre
l'antisémitisme ou de racisme évidemment
il faut le respect la tolérance de
toutes les différences maintenant ça me
fait peur c'est le voilà parce que c'est
vrai aussi que l'on va tomber dans un
politiquement correct total cirque on
pourra plus jamais dire à quelqu'un
qu'il est [ __ ] je pourrais pas vous
traité d'enculé ça pue et rigolo devient
non ça ce sera beaucoup moins drôle
asensi laqsil loi nous empêche de dire
parfois de compenser en mer danse et
vous avez une idée de ce que pourrait
être cette loi parce qu'on a invité
romero ici sans julie at elle si elle
est juste là dans le rouge du miel et à
la russie
on lui a dit mais ça va être quoi cette
loi il a dit vous en faites pas ça vous
touchera pas ne vous en faites pas vous
ardisson baffie tout ça c'est pas grave
évidemment favorables à une loi qui
effectivement sera sera suffisamment
souple pour qu'on puisse continuer à
déconner parce qu'il faut aussi la libre
expression sans insulter et
les personnes homosexuelles comme on n'a
pas le droit d'être raciste d'être
antisémite ou d'être sexiste c'est la
même chose j'ai la chance moi de
travailler dans un milieu non seulement
parisien mais en plus médiatique
artistique où on sait on rencontre plus
facilement des copains ou des copines
homosexuels que dans d'autres milieux
j'imagine que c'est moins facile d'être
ouvrier gay voilà ouais mais c'est pour
ça certainement qu'il faut faire avancer
ce genre de loi contre l'homophobie et
voilà effectivement je peux comprendre
qu'en province dans certains petits
villages ce n'est pas facile d'être gay
mais des vrais débats ça fait avancer le
schmilblick
en revanche forcer les choses comme l'a
fait noël mamère à bègles je ne suis pas
sûr j'ai peur je vous dis que ça pousse
les gens dans leurs retranchements
merci laurent alors le rond on va rester
en famille on va rester dans la dans la
grande famille de la télé je vais vous
faire une interview bal des faux culs
[Musique]
alors accentué alors un très beau cul
l'envoie là qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette rentrée télé laurent perriault dit
la rentrée télé alors la rentrée télé
c'est comme la rentrée scolaire la
rentrée scolaire on a interdit aux
gosses d'avoir quelque chose sur la tête
la rentrée télé c'est interdit aux
gosses avoir quelque chose dans la tête
je pensais pas que cette année les
candidats de la star ac en un charisme
fou
oh bah c'est génial tarak cette année
grâce à gérard louvin sa formule gps
oui oui oui grotesque pathétique stupide
[Applaudissements]
il ya quand même une candidate qui
sortait du lot elle est même carrément
sorti du château c'est celle qui s'est
bourré la gueule
elle pensait que gps ça voulait dire
jean pinard scotch gps et psg dans le
désordre direct dans l'orne ça marche
vous n'avez pas fini égard le
pensionnaire de m6 vous en pensez quoi
alors assez formidable tour à l'autorité
travail mais surtout la blouse way
formidable tout le monde le même
uniforme ça marche toujours ça regardez
au psg il porte le même maillot il en
meilleur résultat
sur canal vous trouvez pas que
l'émission de michel denisot est très
très innovante
abbas est formidable c'est bien non
puisque encore bien je trouve après
comme il ya eu il ya eu guillaume durand
il ya une à guy il ya eu mort à cette bd
frédéric beigbeder emmanuel chain chaque
année on trouve un kamikaze
c'est quand même pas mal et puis les
personnages genre en 3d qui
l'accompagnent ça vous rappelle pas un
peu bill l'extraterrestre de la gaffe
c'est pas les personnages en 3d ça je
trouve ça fort mais surtout qu'il ait
même choisi ardisson et fogiel et le
troisième de chaval ça va trois types
qui font des scores incroyables en prime
à la télévision
les guignols toujours en forme
les guignols superman adore les guignols
ouais vraiment mais je dis sans s'en
faut qu tri ouais ça c'est bien je
regarde tous les soirs c'est ça qu'est
d'or france 2 france3 complémentaires un
petit peu comme sophie davant et pierre
sled c'est magnifique
moi je n'aime pas cette comparaison
plutôt comme marc olivier fogiel et guy
carlier y en a à la finir par bouffer
l'autre c'est mon sens pas du tout
l'absence d'ariane massenet non en même
temps c'est plus facile de faire
décoller ariane que guy carlier
des compagnons problème radio d'arthur
qui veut pas travailler sur la même
radio que coco et ont pas forcément il
ya une grande solidarité entre tous les
animateurs de radio et télévision 20 à
propos de cauet vous trouvez comment son
émission je la trouve en appuyant sur la
une moi je trouve que c'est une super
idée qui l'a collé de m les invités
comme c'est autour d'une table et de
faire des interviews thématique c'est
nouveau c'est original non je sais pas
comment il a eu ces mots on parle un peu
comme dans le cyclisme de transfusion
sanguine voilà il paraît qu'il y aurait
mis du sang d'ardisson ah oui c'est ça
il ya des tests qui ont prouvé sa et en
maintenant on a mélangé les flacons sait
plus qui est qui qui fait quoi
en tous les cas la télé drôlement
talentueuse en ce moment à moi je trouve
si vous trouvez pas que la télé c'est un
art du quotidien laurent oui marco merci
laurent j'aime beaucoup ce que vous
faites
non
voilà
au théâtre de la renaissance les
accueillantes d'ailleurs bien des
missions et brigitte fossey naissant sur
scène
non
voici arielle dombasle
soir bonsoir
non ça va mais oui alors démission il ya
laurent ruquier je suis un petit peu
désolé mais bon pas grave
ben je suis ravi et ce public tellement
beau je le regarde
c'est vrai que sont bordeaux alors
auriel vous avez été questionné
récemment à propos de votre attitude à
la télévision et vous avez déclaré vous
savez quand j'accepte de participer à
une émission je sais ce qu'on attend de
moi et je me prête au jeu
en fait moi je crois vous êtes une
actrice mais toute la journée non on
vous le dit non mais mais mais c'est
comme les photos vous savez on vous dit
soyez naturel mais on est comme ça dans
un studio surchauffée à prendre des pros
des pauses abracadabrante
qu'est-ce que vous prenez comme pose à
brac damas comme vous alors qu'on fasse
des photos ensemble
ouais alors vous êtes une actrice née
quand le matin par exemple quand vous
êtes mauvaise réveil vous vous refaites
laprise voulait dire quand je me lève du
pied gauche oui oui je refais la prise
évidemment et quand vous dites bonjour à
la boulangère présente sol intex tout
préparé quasiment quasiment vous savez
ce qu'ils allaient lui dire en tout cas
je lui dis toujours que son pain est bon
et que j'adore les croissants je
commence par et quand vous êtes dans un
parking par exemple convoyer des caméras
de vidéosurveillance fait attention mais
où ai je mets mon meilleur profil et
puis je fais comme ça et puis je me dis
ah non là ça va pas je vais plutôt être
comme ça ah mais non non lâche horrible
attends je vais mettre comme ça à la
jamais dans un parking sur itunes c'est
son chauffeur qui descend la voiture il
a hérité de la crise tu sais qu ariel
avec bernard ils font relâche le lundi
oui pas pour l'amour vous avez des
doublures corps non à votre avis est ce
que vous méritez un césar pour votre vie
pour ma vie je ne sais pas qui a dit il
faut mettre du talent dans son oeuvre du
génie dans sa vie ben on essaye un peu
de réussir sa vie tous les arizona de ce
que tu es vachement bon
comme tout le monde je sais pas il ya
des hauts et des bas il ya des on est
tous dans l'est dans les tourbillons
l'existence je sais pas vous mais une
très belle formule vous dites il faut
réussir chaque jour comme si c'était une
petite vie ah ça oui c'est vrai c'est
bien je vois toujours chacune de mes
journées comme une mini vie et le soir
quand je mets ma tête sur l'oreiller je
revois dessous vous bon je revois ma
journée et je me dis ouais quels ont été
les moments gracieux vous voyez toute
votre vie en accéléré
avant nous endorment la mini votre mini
vie ouais alors là vous êtes là pour la
promo de votre nouvel album
ouais j'ai voulu faire un retour aux
sources voilà alors là ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que sa maman
armande altaï l'à beaucoup aidé
alors faut savoir c'est que malgré le
succès de votre dernier album extase
vous laissez tomber le lyrique les
arpèges et vous retourner aux sources
effectivement aux grands standards
latinos il ya même un duo avec julio
donc c'est top mais vous avez été élevé
au mexique c'est pas très étonnant final
voilà c'est une chanson que vous
entendiez dans la cuisine quand quand
j'étais petit
les les chansons qui sont ces communs 1
comment dire le le corps même des
musiques cultes que tout toute
l'amérique l'amérique du nord et
l'amérique latine écoute
en fait vous êtes une mexicaine blonde
voilà quand même marrant comme le
mexique rend les gens un peu fou non
mais surtout pas du tout pareil si on
vous mettez à côté de christine bravo
croirai jamais donné dans le même pays
[Applaudissements]
non mais moi j'ai c'est vrai que je suis
très peiné mexicaine dans l'âme parce
que j'ai vécu 18 en inde mexique et ma
première langue c'est l'espagnol oui
c'est la première fois que vous exprimez
votre culture tex-mex parce que jusque
là en fait vous liez vous vous intégrez
voilà parisienne dont vous aviez
toujours caché noël cette gêne
vous savez que quand on arrive en france
on est intimidé par les français et
j'avais beau j'étais allé au lycée
franco mexicain et je parlais français
mes parents sont français
moi j'étais né aux états-unis ma mère
aussi mais on était français mais arrivé
à paris avec les français ça fait très
très peur donc moi je les jouais super
low profile
et encore on me disait toujours elle est
ou bottes j'aime bien je la joue et le
profane
on disait les too much tu es un sous
titrage ce soir comment ça se passe non
mais le dire il faut il faut se plier
aux goûts des français et tout ça et les
étrangers le connaissent bien qu'en vo
on veut être assimilée dans un pays
ben on essaye de d'observer puis monde
un peu de mimétisme mais c'est vrai que
moi je suis latine je suis tempérament
talent je suis bavarde et puis ma langue
c'est l'espagnol donc voilà alors
aujourd'hui arielle dombasle
c'est découvre dj
[Musique]
oh
et
m
oh
ça me blesse un menu
mutlu comment s'y connaissent tous les
jours le dimanche
c'est bien
tulu
m
à cali des leçons
quoi
enfin
[Musique]
[Rires]
et
je verrai
l'état
tous les bouchons des chiffres
e
ainsi pas sur le champ
oui
mais comme
[Musique]
qui sait
qui se sent
voilà l'album s'appelle mamans et leurs
amis
là c'est ron ron hyne coca cola
[Musique]
organe est ce que vous connaissez le
frère de dalida
le frère de dalida ville de floride
alors oui nous connaissons j'avais ce
qu'il veut et orlando non orlando exige
le clip
mais oui regardez votre caméra il dit
magnéto serge thank you hell magnetico
[Musique]
boilard à moi-même coca cola à exxon à
maghama même
alors là et puis à sa merci
avec julio et j'ai agi
[Musique]
puis comme
qui sait
tu sens
qui s'éteint
dimon
moussa
et
samedi
[Musique]
m
son bal avec julio iglesias que la
blessure comment ça s'est passé avec lui
j'ai bien passée c'était formidable
parce que mon producteur marc di
domenico m'a dit mais oui tes chansons
latines tout ça c'est formidable enfin
il faut quand même tout à coup et
l'ombre et latino qu'on la rose de
tercio pelo mouiller mystérieux sont
alors on s'est dit mais qui pourrait
incarner comme ça le latin lover des
voeux est alors tout à coup il à
découvrir les six mois j'ai dit mais je
le connais pas m y connais pas et voudra
jamais et puis on se dit c'est un rêve
j'espère bonnement essayons et alors ils
ont envoyé les nerfs et ils ont envoyé
ma voix à maya me vire ou lyon et puis
ça a marché
voilà et ça c'est vraiment génial parce
que bon il est tellement tellement aimé
pape il avoue elle-même c'est à la fois
thompson
alors bravo l'album est réalisé par marc
di domenico qui est l'homme qui a
ressuscité henri salvador
c'est quelqu'un de très très faim et qui
qui a d'abord trouvé tous mes musiciens
et donc c'est lui qui a permis que ce
que se disent que cette harmonie et sept
au québec la timide elle est très fort
alors vous avez fait tout en une prise
d'un live
marc vous les leçons des années 40 50
espèces de son comme ça très
mélancolique cette douceur sa dispose de
choses alors donc on l'a pris un micro
des années 40 et on a chanté life avec
les musiciens
donc ça rend 7,7 enfin bon cette
sonorité confrères réussir ya le bravo
très bon alors
donc quand on vous voit qu'entre gaulois
écouter ses chansons
on vous voit différemment d'habitude
vous êtes assez comme ça à ces
guerrières assez vous êtes complètement
abandonné ariel on aurait dit ah oui
vraiment une petite fille la pauvrette
chikita africains mais c'est vrai un
vraiment mais moi mon rêve ce serait que
les gens mettent le disque et ai envie
de danser le slot c'est ça l'idée
c'est le rapprochement des décors assez
mexique du mexique
il est en forme routier alors vous êtes
à l'affiché du dernier lelouch
oui bah vous étiez à la fiche parce
qu'il est plus trop à la fiche mais bon
ben c'est à dire que c'était une
trilogie
oui on a deux autres derrières les
autres ya et on est à peu près sans
capteur on est très très nombreux 1
il ya plus de gens partager via tous
dans un état plus de gens dans le film
que dans les salles presque avec
celle inclue ans de l'enfant vous êtes
dans les deux autres épisodes assurément
je suis très peu dans le premier jeu
fait qu'apparaître mais je suis beaucoup
dans le deuxième à schwedt arrière votre
disque s'appelant amor amor vous ne
serez pas étonné qu'on fasse une
interview amor amor ariel est ce que par
amour vous accepteriez de jouer dans un
film pornographique
si c'est bernard henry qui filme bon il
me filmerait avec amour oui mais bon
mais je je je suis d'accord mais à une
condition c'est que le film ne sorte pas
voilà qui ferait qu'on vient de voir
deux films chez vous
est-ce que par un mot vous seriez prête
à vous m repassage
oh ben ça bien sûr ah bon oui oui
d'ailleurs quand j'avais 12 ans il
m'avait donné un petit refaire à
repasser et j'adorais brûler les trucs
avec sa fille fer à cheval
mais là oui si c'est turbo vapeur et
tout ça pourquoi comme question il
s'appelle ariel pas fabuleux par amour
avait suivi sur y est prête à mettre une
autre fille dans votre lit bas l'autre
fils et moi je peux jouer plusieurs
rôles à fait d'accord et un autre garçon
un beau garçon et un autre garçon bas
c'est lui
on est d'accord il est très fort aussi
par amour est ce que vous pourriez
tromper bernard et henri tromper mais
s'il me le demande et je pourrais le
faire à
c'est vrai mais en toile à pied vite ça
c'est une vraie femme
non alors mais ça c'est bien mais ça le
rendait ça le rendrait très malheureux
s'il avait envie de se faire du mal à
s'il avait envie de se faire très mal
or et qui me le demander ah c'est beau
ce machin le feraient par amo est ce que
vous pourriez vous faire raser la tête
et sans matériel par monsieur
mais mais mais mais j'adore monsieur
propre à moi je le bouquet parce que je
trouve qu'il a beaucoup de style avec
ses bus est balancé lantus par amour est
ce que vous pourriez accepter une gifle
à ben tout de suite par amour évidemment
mais bien sûr ça vous est une gifle par
amo est ce que vous pourriez quitter la
france pour toujours moi je la quitte
souvent déjà un pour toujours pour
toujours
ouais bien sûr mais j'en aurais la
nostalgie je serai chagrine mais je le
ferai part à mots vous pourriez vivre à
mulhouse à mulhouse
oui attendez à rien avant de dire oui tu
allais à mulhouse à rien tout ça ne vaut
pas un clair de lune à mulhouse
c'est ça non non c'est moche c'est mon
amour est ce que vous pourriez renoncer
au sexe par amour an auparavant ça c'est
quand même ce serait très difficile on
vous aimez un type qui peut plus voilà
oui je le ferai comme com com com
comment dire comme une sorte de mystique
de l'amour une privation absolue qui me
ferait d'ailleurs mais au bout de quinze
jours mais je me roulerait par terre je
serais même et je serai un havrais
j'entrerai dans une sorte de dolorisme
peut être bourg marqué wee cc sauf
rouennaise et la course ou
sainte-thérèse d'avila l'extase de
sainte thérèse il paraît que si on est
dans l'abstinence totale on arrive à des
extases bon s'intéressent elles crient
quand on abaissera
un amour si vous pourriez vous
prostituées ah si bernard vous le
demande bien sûr ben oui j'irai
rolala mais bon je sais pas ce que ça
donnerait je sais pas vous y pensez des
fois j -p en irak de nombreux groupes
épopée promener dans rome la nuit comme
ça elle s'offrait à tous les hommes là
on entre dans des choses qui sont très
scabreuse moins scabreux est-ce que par
un mot vous pourriez arrêté de tourner
des films et christian clavier
mais bernard henri m christian clavier
ah oui oui le trouve très sympa je
pourrais m'arrêter de tourner des films
bien sûr ça mais avec christian clavier
oui bien sûr mais j'aime beaucoup
christian clavier mais bien sûr j'arrête
vous aimez les films faits chant
claviers mais oui bien sûr jacquouille
tout ça mais tout le monde les avait dit
pour sa part à mort et ce courrier vous
mettre au tricot
ah ouais ça je trouve très sensuelle une
femme qui tricotent non mais c'est vrai
un point à l'endroit un point à l'envers
alors amo est ce que vous pourriez
changer de sexe ariel mais j'aurais pas
envie parce que parce que je trouve que
être une fille c'est fantastique c'est
vraiment mal âge seriez une fille quand
même pardon vous resteriez une fille
quand même vous auriez un sexe d'homme
par amour
ah mais vous voulez dire que je serai
comme ça mais en aphrodite
voilà pourquoi t'as garder tes fiches
sur amanda lear
non
[Musique]
or
maintenant bruno gaccio et philippe
bilger
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir nom bruno gaccio qui mange le
connaissez le patron des guignols
philippe bilger vous êtes un petit peu
moins connus bien train vous êtes avocat
général alors c'est quoi un avocat
général un avocat général c'est un kipré
en ce qui me concerne fait aussi une
fonction puisque depuis 8 ans 9 ans je
suis avocat général à la cour d'assises
de paris
voilà n'ayez pas peur et les passions du
tout alors vous avez été contacté tous
les deux par la production de vis ma vie
pour échanger vos vies 1 comment ça se
passait super bien
ouais tu es devenu avocat général d'un
mec c'est absolument fabuleux d'être
accusateur public
ouais et en plus ça j'ai appris ça avec
philippe bilger c'est que ça implique
une responsabilité terrible parce que
quand on est accusateur public on a un
rôle extrêmement important dans le
tribunal parce que on a les faits on a
un crime généralement devant soi et on
est obligé de déterminer la vraie peine
la peine extrêmement juste aride accord
s'était fixé les verts actuellement mais
on peut même requérir devaki tu mens
lorsqu'on estime que l'accusé et qui ne
sent femme est déjà arrivé vous avez
demandé perpétuité déjà filé bien sûr
bien sûr mais je le dis sans aucune
volupté prenez moi je voudrais pas mêler
la tragédie judiciaire au divertissement
même intelligent savard est ce qu'il est
dans le bouquin vous avez fait un livre
tous les deux qui s'appelle le guignol
et le magistrat sur la liberté
d'expression vous le décrivez comme
gauchistes anarchisant anti-américain
anti religieux anti puces anti tout en
fumant fait tout l'intérêt du dialogue
parce que si le dialogue avait été
facile
il aurait été satisfaisant que je
l'entretiennent avec moi même et il me
semble que c'est peut-être le grand
mérite du livre s'est créé un dialogue
sans complaisance violent qui peut nous
renvoyer l'un et l'eau dans des camps
très opposées mais où on a tenté
d'appliquer les règles de la liberté
d'expression et toi tu le décris comme
juré akato élitiste et culturels moi je
c'est vrai c'est vrai absolument bien
alors tout commence au bar des sports à
issy les moulineaux
devant une mauresque un soir alors pas
du tout alors le pitch le pire c'est la
liberté d'expression et ces limites
alors plus at-elle perdu ou gagné du
terrain ces dernières années voilà c'est
le sait le thème du bouquin ouais c'est
un peu ça oui depuis octobre il s'en est
passé quand même quelques unes de
sympathiques notamment dassault qui a
acheté un tas de bouquins de journaux en
france et qui dit très clairement que
ben il va un style élancé livre quelques
idées saines les siennes que j'ai un peu
les jetons ombre pour les journalistes
du figaro notamment il ya une espèce
d'inquiétude chez moi qui existait avant
parce que murdoch et turner où on sur un
milliard d'individus la possibilité de
leur laver le cerveau parce que fait le
lait en france
je trouve que la liberté d'expression
elle n'a jamais été aussi apparente on a
l'impression qu'on peut tout dire mais
jamais dans ce flot de paroles des
choses intéressantes m'ont été dit et il
ya de moins en moins que de pluralité
philippe nouveau reproché aux guignols
leur manque de tendresse leur manque de
pitié vous parler d'une sorte d'aigreur
qui les pousse à une surenchère haineuse
aujourd'hui le problème c'est que le
rire n'est plus celui du faible à
l'encontre du puissance gêne d'en rire
c'est qu'il est institutionnalisée
ancrée il est devenu une puissance qu'on
au flux conteste moi je crois pas du
tout non parce que d'abord les émissions
d'humour comme les guignols ou celle de
thierry sont pas des émissions qui font
forcément le plus d'audience parce que
l'humour engagé n'est pas un humour
fédérateur des que dès qu'on se
positionne sur
/ je sais pas moi sur une certaine
idéologie qu'elle soit de gauche ou de
droite d'ailleurs on segmente une partie
du public
donc on à partir de là on peut pas dire
qu'on soit une puissance et attend
arrête parce qu'à ton sujet de ses skis
dis à ton sujet bilger il dit ruquier
riz en permanence car il est pas sûr qu
il va faire rire et je les lui sa mère
mais c'est vrai j'ai raison il a raison
mais moi je préfère rire de moi-même
parce que je vais pas attendre ismar lui
mais vous avez tort je vous avais tort
parce que je vous assure jamais ce sont
les rares fois où j'ai regardé votre
émission il y a des gens qui m'ont fait
rire et vous même en particulier
simplement ce qui me gêne c'est qu'on
n'impose l'étiquette rire sur des
personnes qui n'ont pas ce talent gfr ça
va pas s'arrêter au bout car tout cela
est bien leur pareil pour baffie c'est à
dire que vous dites que ma fille en
rajoute une couche fou du roi avril
couche de méchanceté et de sexe oui de
manière artificielle devant un public
robotisée ridicule des projets que j'ai
un nom mais je le
s'ils savaient comme ils me font plaisir
bien alors tout ça nous amène
naturellement à parler de tout le monde
en parle on va régler le problème tout
de suite puis après on verra ce que vous
dites d'autres dans votre bouquin alors
c'est vous philippe vous dites quand
thierry ardisson demande à michel rocard
si sucer c'est tromper fait-il bon usage
de sa liberté d'expression
alors je suis désolé de vous le dire
vous êtes avocat général vous envoyer
des gens en prison à perpète
donc vaut mieux vous renseigner avant
parce que présentée comme ça bien sûr
que c'est ridicule de voir michel rocard
et lui dire est ce que celui-ci s'est
trompé c'est vrai comme ça c'est à mon
avis un abus de la liberté d'expression
vous auriez raison
le problème c'est qu'il faut savoir
qu'avant ça en sept étapes et 25 minutes
d'interview de michel rocard sur le ps
eu sur la csg etc
et après il ya une petite interview
formaté qui est un jeu qui s'appelle à
l'arthrose
est-ce que voilà est-ce que sucer c'est
tromper mais ramener cette interview de
25 minutes à sa franchise rispal latine
ça vous semble pas c'est pas la question
qui me choque c'est y répondre et vous
voyez moi je trouve tout à fait normal
que vous pouviez toutes les questions
d'ailleurs qui fraîche pour vous les
vins interdire mais je n'y répondrai pas
vous savez vous quand même savoir que
michel rocard il s'est marié trois fois
oui
la dernière fois qu'il s'est marié
devait avoir 70 ans 5e les femmes et qui
n'est pas surpris par cette question
mais on peut les aimer sans être obligé
de répondre dans ces conditions à une
question qui relève un petit peu de la
team
oui vous en conviendrez en conviendront
à ton mec là un certain type extra bien
fait pas prendre collard
alors vous parlez également aussi d'une
interview de airy routier qui a fait un
livre sur bernard arnault le patron de
lvmh et vous dites dans le bouquin avec
gaccio que cette interview était
enregistré une première semaine non
diffusés et re enregistré la semaine
d'après vous dites parce qu'il ya eu des
pressions les avocats de bernard arnault
pas du tout pas du tout il ya eu
simplement des remarques du service
juridique de france 2 où moi je donnais
l'impression d'endosser les propos des
routiers donc ça devenait répréhensible
et la semaine d'après on l'a fait sans
que j'endosse les propos de airy routier
simplement ce que vous oubliez de
remarquer quand même c'est que c'est la
seule émission on a reçu airy routier
quand même un surnom mais les autres ils
ont eu peur de bernard arnault jeu là
vous me donnez un démenti qui me touche
qui vous convaincre - ouais même si on
sait plaire enfants deux fois mais il
arrive que vous invitiez des gens bien
qui me gêne c'est quand vous faites
venir des gens qui n'ont pas brillé par
quelque chose de positif je pense un
ancien chanteur que vous faites venir
uniquement parce que à deux reprises il
a été pris et condamné pour conduite en
état alcoolique
jean jacques debout et non dans sa fiat
fini non si vous relève qui me gêne
c'est un petit peu alors avec votre
votre aura médiatique
la prime que vous donnez à des êtres et
à des comportements qui peut être fière
été remarquable moi je l'aimais bien
maman qui chantait il ya 20 ans mais qui
aujourd'hui n'apporte rigoureusement
rien vous voyez ya tant de gens qui ne
viendront jamais chez vous et qui font
remarquable vous avez raison mais
chantal goya
alors on arrive à thierry meyssan voilà
que ce sera la dernière je crois pas
parler que le tout le monde en parle on
appris par ben excusez moi thierry
meyssan bon vous en avez entendu
tellement parlé que vous en avez
peut-être assez non non moi je me suis
expliqué de langeais gg tic
j'ai été abusé par l'appartenance de
thierry meyssan réseau voltaire
c'est vrai qu'il avait beaucoup lutter
aussi contre le front national donc
c'est quelqu'un qui au départ je
trouvais plutôt crédible
bon j'ai pas pris assez de précautions
oratoires camp quand je les ai invités
ici effectivement comme vous dites je
m'en suis expliquée mais vous dites
aussi dans votre bouquin que ce qu'a dit
thierry meyssan dans cette émission ne
tombent pas sous le coup de la loi non
non non bien sûr toutes les absurdités
heureusement ne sont pas pénalement
répréhensible oui oui non et puis c'est
vrai quand même des choses qui sont
inexpliqués dans cette affaire on a
quand même trouvé le passeport de
mohammed atta au sommet des ruines du
world trade center
quand on pense que le mec s'était
encastré dans l'immeuble avec son avion
c'est vrai que c'est un peu bizarre
qu'on retrouve le passeport c'est des
choses que les gens haïssent français
n'ont pas cherché à expliquer une des
choses les plus intéressantes qui avait
été dit ici c'était quand quelqu'un dit
qu'un avion qu'aucun avion on est rentré
dans le pentagone le minimum quand on
est directeur du journal c'est d'envoyer
immédiatement quelqu'un pour vérifier
oui ce qui n'a jamais été fait rester
mais une chose acquise c'était comme ça
nous avait dit que donc on l'admet voilà
alors vous ne parlez pas heureusement
pour vous que de tout le monde en parle
et de laurent ruquier vous parlez aussi
dans un chapitre qui s'appelle rire de
tout de la fameuse histoire d des
crevettes le sketch que bruno gaccio
avait écrit pour patrick timsit
vous revenez là dessus et la question
que vous posez c'est faut-il qu'on
allait la faute de goût en fait c'est ça
que vous aimez pénalisation du bon goût
du bon goût du mauvais goût est ce que
la loi peut dire le bon goût oui ça
c'est vachement intéressant parce qu'on
finirait donc tous en taule non parce
qu'avec quand on fait deux cent
cinquante émission parents forcément on
est pas de bon goût à chaque minute et
l'histoire des crevettes ckoi écrit le
sketch il a voulu raconter je le répète
je tombe sous le coup de la loi donc je
vais pas me gêner
on avait su rester pas c'était pas une
histoire de crevettes on n'imaginait
qu'un garagiste qu'un chirurgien pardon
agirait avec le même comportement qu'un
garagiste et donc il ya un type qui
venait chercher sa fille qui était
censé être opéré il n'allait pas prête
au nac est dessus l'on apprenne la
terminer par contre j'ai fini la facture
et tout ça on va changer les poumons
c'est pourquoi les plumes on y va parce
que elle et des poumons pour y aller
fumer du charbon de bois ou quoi mais
vous avez pris ou les pouvoirs sur un
mongolien on les a pris et commence à un
mongolien pourrait baisser des
mongoliens c'est des prototypes
c'est toi c'est fabriqué comme ça et
puis c'est comme les crevettes roses à
part la tête tout est bon et tout d'un
coup le sketch est passé pendant des
mois et des mois au théâtre des années
en cassette et puis un jour il est passé
sur france 2 et puis il ya un parent de
mongoliens qui a trouvé ce propos
absolument horrible ce qui est je le
comprends ça c'est quand évidemment
qu'on comprend ça et donc il ya eu
procès et puis là on est parti dans une
sorte de délire que timsit quand ils
allaient quand il est allé au tribunal
il y avait des pancartes dehors a bâti
en feat avec des mongoliens et tous
étaient il ya des associations qui se
sont mis et patrick a eu un peu peur et
je le comprends parce qu'en fait il joue
sa carrière aussi c'est un peu compliqué
pour lui moi je suis derrière j'ai écrit
la connerie bon moi je reste chez moi ça
me pose pas de problème lui par contre
il est devant c'est son image c'est ce
qu'il est et donc il a préféré dire on
arrête là on s'embrasse on fait une
assoc hélas une parole qui était très
belle au tribunal l'a dit si vous pensez
qu'en me condamnant vous allez trouver
le mal absolu et que je suis le
représentant de ce mal absolu contre le
malheur de ses enfants alors condamné
moi ça vaut la peine si vous pensez que
c'est juste une connerie que j'ai dérapé
vaut mieux s'arrêter tout de suite parce
que ça n'avait aucun sens si un jour
fait une blague sur les dactylos vous
allez avoir le syndicat décennaux
dactylo qu'ils n'ont pas de blagues sur
les secteurs les corses les homos les
femmes et et ainsi de suite
alors ça va jusqu'à des cas plus graves
comme effectivement les les trisomiques
mais voilà ça veut dire qu'il faut quand
même faire attention et que le débat
revient alors dans mes chats joutes moi
juste une chose c'est que la blessure
elle peut être à mon avis que dans la
récurrence c'est à dire ceux ci un
comique passer son temps à se moquer des
handicapés vieux temps un problème par
contre la vanne qui sort comme ça ou
qu'on lâche comme ça dans un contexte
donné dans un sketch donnée qui n'est
pas un sketch sur les trisomiques là
pour le coup qui a un sketch sur autre
chose je vois pas on va rester dans la
faute de goût si on peut pas condamner
la faute de goût pourquoi tout le monde
a fait chier ce pauvre patrick sébastien
avec avec casser du noir à ce moment là
c'est pas tellement qu'ils fassent ce
sketch casser du noir c'était pas ça qui
nous gêne c'est qu'il avait ramené le
pen et qui riait avec et on se disait
non non on fait passer à bordel et lui
au lieu de se dire bon les avez raison
les mecs j'ai fait le con qui sait il
s'est mis dans un oui c'est les intellos
qui m'attaque je suis le pauvre rugbyman
tout le monde m'en veut il sait il
s'enfermer dans cette espèce de crise et
ses billes crise et nous on est on
n'était pas là dessus on était juste sur
rai a vite pas le pen les connais moi je
pars avec et dieudonné alors philippe
comment pensez vous que la justice les
traitaient moi je je trouve qu'ici je
suis bien l'histoire judiciaire de
dieudonné il a été relaxé deux foires je
crois est condamné une troisième fois je
trouve que c'est discutable c'est peut
être répréhensible des gens ont pu être
choquées mais je trouve que dans une
société qui veut être une société de
liberté il me semble que là pour une
fois la jurisprudence a été avivée en le
relaxant et en plus lorsque je vois les
tentatives qui ont été faites à fond
l'encontre après je trouve que c'est
scandaleux c'est d'accord avec ça je
n'ai rien à ajouter ceux qui parlent
bien il parle bien c'est un vrai plaisir
de 10 ans et avec quoi
ouais je n'ai pas dîné tous les soirs
avec mais c'est un mec c'est un mec bien
et quand vous faisiez le bouquin vous
faisiez c'est à table
commencez à table et puis on débat on a
fini par écrit parce qu'on se parle et
plus on a on a préféré arrêter la table
parce que celles non pas parce qu'en
plus dans mes hippique aunis est
vraiment
[Applaudissements]
vous dites que ça rejoint la sphère
dieudonné aujourd'hui il est impossible
de critiquer la politique israélienne
sans être taxé d'antisémitisme vous
appelez ça non plus de la liberté
d'expression mais de la timidité
d'expression oui je dirais que ça n'est
peut-être pas aussi fif thématiques que
je le dis mais parce qu'il est évident
que certains font passer un
antisémitisme derrière une apparente
critique politique j'en ai conscience
mais tout de même on va très vite dans
l'accusation d'antisémitisme
lorsque vous avez des esprits à
l'évidence moralement impeccable kif
permet de critiquer la politique
d'israël
ils ne sont absolument pas en qui fait
me moi je suis en train de réclamer en
ce moment une loi pour accusations
d'antisémitisme abusif
parce qu'on ne peut pas continuer à dire
à assimiler des gens aux nazis à des
exterminateurs
il faut il faudra un moment arrêter ça
on est contre la politique d'israël on a
le droit d'être même de rire du rite
juif
moi j'aurais le droit de me moquer du
pape pourquoi se moquer des musulmans
sans que ça pose d'énormes problèmes
et pourquoi dès qu'on arrive sur le rite
juif avec les papillotes de trucs là en
disant je trouve ça ridicule
ah non non antisémite un nom j'ai le
droit de rire de ce rite aussi il est
normal qu'on soit plus prudent quand on
se moque des rites religieux juif que
catholique ou musulman c'est que tout
simplement dans notre pays plus
récemment il ya quand même eu un
massacre antisémites alors que les
massacres catholiques ou musulmans dans
notre pays en tout cas sont beaucoup
plus anciens c'est quand même une des
raisons pour lesquelles on se doit
d'être un peu plus prudents car la
dérision ce qu'on avait dit à dieudonné
à l'époque on lui on lui avait dit ça on
lui avait dit les juifs c'est pas les
belges ou les suisses quoi ce maire m
on a pas tués pendant la guerre des
millions de belges des millions de
suisses sous préfet explique t elle je
vous suis bien sûr
seriez vous savez là que l'idée on peut
rire de tout mais pas avec n'importe qui
et ben voilà ça c'est quand même la
grande leçon parce que vous parliez de
tout à coup il histoire de casser d'une
loi je regrette mais en effet à chaque
chaque situation en fait ce sont presque
toujours des cas très précis et s'il ya
eu une réaction comme ça épidermique de
la population et que les choses ne
passent pas c'est parce qu'elles ne
doivent pas passer et je crois que mais
là une réaction de la population oui
c'est une des journalistes s'étaient
fixés nous bêtement on a tous sauté
dessus bêtement
non c'est l'esprit mais notre sens
nettement parce que casser du noir ccc
les alors la loi sur l'homophobie art et
il en a parlé au début de l'émission et
des façons j'ai pas grand chose à
ajouter c'est vrai que quand une loi
permet comme le pacs c'est dire que
c'est un fait précis le pacs ont dit
vous avez le droit que vous soyez deux
hommes deux femmes un frère une soeur
même je crois que c'est possible
vous avez le droit si vous vivez
ensemble depuis très longtemps d'avoir
les mêmes droits
donc qu'une loi rendre le monde meilleur
rendent donne une espèce d'harmonie
c'est bien quand tout d'un coup cette
loi risque de nous empêcher d'en rire
d'une institution puisque si le mariage
devient une institution va se moquer des
mariages homos autant que d autres
mariage le jour on se moquera de son
mariage et la mort là il ya une loi
n'avait pas le droit de vous moquer de
cellules a hâte en effet pas chier
maintenant t'as pas le droit
donc là la loi je sais main franchement
je préfèrerais qu'il en ait pas et alors
sur la pédophilie vous dites des choses
très intéressantes vous dites on est
traités différemment lorsque l'année
andré gide ou gabriel matzneff robert
tulipiers de lons le saunier un
quinquennat quel prix nobel de
littérature et l'autre qui prend 15 en
quadri et je lui pose des questions je
lui pose la question le bouquin je lui
dis est ce qu'à un moment un jeune
marocain qui se tapent gide qui a 12 ans
est-ce qu'il sort grandi de cette
expérience parce qu'il aura côtoyé
quelqu'un d'exceptionnel est-ce que
l'aspect exceptionnel d'un être me rends
à un acte comme nature d'un film
acceptable qui doit se poser la question
cegid qui doit se poser la question de
respecter à quelqu'un de mineur jeunesse
à milan m
devant la 17e chambre correctionnelle si
je l'avais eu ça m'aurait pas posé de
problème de requérir contre lui parce
que la littérature excuse tout c'est ça
la question arrive en tout cas c'est un
cetain c'est un très grand débat et il
dure depuis
depuis vingt siècles est ce que l'art
excuse tout bon il faut poser cette
question est les gommages dont le livre
ça c'est juste pour vendre
ok bruno gaccio fini pilger
février chez flammarion que beaucoup à
perdre à frangy son pyjama
j'aurais dû m'y attendais
on va faire une interview oui mais c'est
facile bruno tu fais ma phrase je ne
serai pas auteur des guignols toute ma
vie mais faut bien gagner la sienne
j'adore michel denisot mais il est
toujours là
stéphane bern est franchement très drôle
mais pourquoi canal l'esprit canal mais
pas mort mais il est quand même dès
l'entamé par contrat je n'ai pas le
droit de critiquer canal mais mais j'ai
moins en moins envie de critiquer canala
mais je trouve que j'ai suffisamment dit
le contraire pour pouvoir aujourd'hui
dire avec autant de sincérité ce que je
pense la grille de cette année
contrairement à ce que vous disiez tout
à l'heure bande de sa loin elle est
plutôt bien ouais c'est très nouveau
c'est vrai que c'est très innovant c'est
pas forcément innovant c'est plutôt bien
1 j'aimerais bien monter sur scène mais
j'ai pas les couilles je viens de sortir
un livre très intelligent sur la liberté
d'expression mais on va avoir du mal à
le vendre bon disons qu'il est drôle
l'air de rien comme ça mais il est
vachement marrant il est vachement
intelligent les mails les guignols n'ont
pas de pouvoir politique mais mais il
aimerait en avoir du pouvoir c'est comme
je le dis dans le livre si on avait dû
pouvoir il y aurait plus de maladies
auraient plus d'hommes politiques qui
tape dans la caisse et il y aurait plus
de femmes qui portent des bottines
blanches et des vestes en jean à franges
je n'ai rien contre mon physique mais
mais bon si les filles vous pouviez me
lâcher deux minutes ça serait sympa
dis moi alors comment ça se passait sur
le marché là non ben comme dans le
marché je fais jouer la concurrence ça
va et bien la dame incité bronze et
ebola donc très mal
écoute je m'occupe de mon corps et ça se
voit si tu veux après je m'occupe du
tien
c'est ma soirée
mimie mathy de m'excite
absolument pas mais j'aimerais bien
savoir ce que ça fait quand même bien
fait que répondre à ça je suis gaulé
comme un dieu mais mais ça sert pas
souvent je suis une star chez les gays
mais j'ai jamais vraiment essayé plus
que ça non j'essayais bêtement mais bon
moi aussi mais ça ne l'a pas ton truc
complètement
c'est en fait le truc chez les garçons
c'est assez simple je sais pas comment
c'est chez les filles mais nous on a un
truc là si c'est comme ça c'est que ça
nous plaît si c'est comme ça c'est que
ce noël voilà c'est très simple donc
quand c'est comme ça tu dis c'est pas
mon truc
voilà donc c'est pas ton truc là pas mon
truc j'ai envie de vous thierry may mais
quant à bruno gaccio
magistrat
et c'est pas mario
on me donne monsieur
messieurs
[Musique]
philippe merci d'avoir été avec nous en
tous les cas je vous laisser filer merci
thierry d'avoir invité quelqu'un qui
avant de vous rencontrer n'était pas
inconditionnel voilà c'est le style de
la maison
et maintenant
10 heures
ouais 6 yohann thuram
thuram durable mais là mais c'est vrai
il est
m
[Musique]
d
djaballah bonsoir bonsoir simon lebon et
john taylor bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous alors vous revenez après vingt ans
de silence discographique ensemble bien
sûr il ya eu des morceaux séparément de
parts de trois par trois mais c'est la
première fois aujourd'hui depuis 20 ans
que le groupe se reforme complètement et
nous en sommes très heureux
merci d'être là à dire que tu manges si
nous sommes rego c'est pour un excellent
public est ici renard alors ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que duran duran a
vendu 70 millions d'albums
c'était une véritable duranne duranne
magna à l'époque des deux côtés de
l'atlantique et comme on a appelé les
les beatles les fab fort on a appelé les
du remdh uran les failles fat
voilà donc c'était vraiment énorme
pourquoi ça s'est arrêté saimone écoutez
je crois que c'est un effet de mode il
faut bien voir que avec le temps les
choses évoluent il ya des questions de
mode dans le domaine de la pop pendant
quelques années
vous sortez quelque chose de nouveau et
puis ensuite les choses évoluent changes
puis à ce moment là il faut que vous
essayez de vous et de vous adapter
faut vous écrivez une nouvelle chanson
vous fassiez des choses nouvelles il
faut pas avoir peur non plus parce que
les médias peuvent vous vous faire
partir vous faire peur et si vous voulez
faire une carrière qui dure et bien il
faut continuer d'écrire des chansons
alors pourquoi ça recommence au bout de
quinze ans on se rend compte que ceux
avec qui elle a eu des difficultés avec
lesquels on s'est peut-être disputé au
bout de quinze ans après on a passé au
bout de 15 ans ce qui nous paraissait
les trous de cul nous paraissent très
sympa tout bas
et là on se dit on se rend pas compte de
ce qu'on a les pins lui que le trou du
cul vous connaissez ce qui veut dire
qu'il faut dire aussi c'est que vous
avez fêté l'anniversaire des 25 ans de
durand durable et que vous avez vu un
tel accueil
c'était sold out et à des prix très cher
900 euros la place
et vous vous êtes dit c'est peut-être le
moment d'y retourner et finalement les
choses les occasions qui se présentent
assez rarement dans une vie et si on
n'avait pas saisi cette occasion il
aurait fallu attendre dix ans de plus
puis voilà aujourd'hui ils reviennent
avec ça
[Musique]
extrait de leur nouvel album qui
s'appelle astronautes
est ce que vous connaissez orlando
hollande hollande où il ya encore eu des
buts non non non le frère je vais
inviter à orlando et orlando il exige le
clip
voilà you want to see you vidéo orlando
want to see guide et au saut du loup
camera and you stay together magnéto
serge prises vidéo
magnette auxerrois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà richard iii de sunrise extrait du
nouvel album de durham durable qui
s'appelle astronautes voilà alors le nom
durant durable vient d'un personnage de
barbarella le film de roger vadim et
c'est très marrant parce que quand vous
avez commencé à jouer à birmingham
vous jouiez dans un club qui s'appelait
le barbare et la barbarella c'était un
club hyper connue à birmingham et
c'était quelque chose que tu est
particulièrement populaire pendant la
période punk quand on n'était qu'à
moitié
mais un soir effectivement le film
barbarella est passé à la télé et on
cherchait un nom pour notre groupe et à
l'époque tous les groupes avaient un nom
comme les clashs les sex pistols et d'un
etc et on s'est dit turin duranne mais
c'est différent
et puis ensuite quand on est venu en
france les gens nous ont dit pourquoi si
vous êtes plus mais johnson du bord du
quai du pont oui absolument
c'est un super nom duran duran non mais
c'est vrai c'est un truc tu peux pas
l'oublier mois 2 durant la même table
c'est beaucoup alors vous alors vous
êtes marié de vie depuis 20 ans avec une
femme sublime qui est une des plus
jolies femmes du monde
un mannequin top model des années 80 il
s'appelle yasmine par vannes est un jour
le magazine rolling stone américain vous
a posé la question pourquoi les
rockstars époux style des top models et
vous avez répondu parce qu'ils peuvent
il ajouté
c'est la même réponse qu'à la question
pourquoi les chiens se lève-t-il les
couilles que bill clinton
il m'a piqué ma chute mais blague parce
que quelqu'un qui veut dire monsieur le
président pourquoi vous êtes ouvert et
venez faire une pipe dans la maison
blanche la réponse parce que je pouvais
pour alors ils vous arrivent des trucs
terribles ça et moi nous avait reçu une
lettre d'une fan qui vous dit ton fils
va à l'université
il a 21 ans il va bien et je n'ai jamais
dit que tu étais son père et dans ces
cas-là vous montrer la lettre à vos
travaux de femmes à vous êtes allé lui
apporter montré la lettre absolument
j'ai rien à lui cacher il faut être
clair sur les trucs comme ça
enfin quand même c'était disons une
surprise une situation assez curieuse
parce que bon c'est elle est
complètement anonyme d'ailleurs je ne
sais pas si c'est si c'est un canard ou
si c'est la vérité j'en sais rien en
tout cas c'est une belle histoire
alors john vous vous êtes le fondateur
du fondateur du groupe
vous aussi vous êtes sorti avec de très
beaux tops models vous allez mener une
vraie vie de pop star
et puis ça s'est quand même terminé dans
une sérieuse addiction à la cocaïne
j'adore alors lui il peut parler des
super nanas qui s'est tapé et moi on
parle de mes problèmes de drogue quel a
été le meilleur moment dans votre vie de
pop star quand on a créé groupe
lorsqu'on est elle aux états unis et
tout ce qu'on a fait pour la première
fois la première fois vous allez à la
télé comme celle aux etats unis la
première fois que vous faites ceci cela
ça c'est des grands moments évidemment
mais bon tout va bien le réel
quel a été le pire moment de cette
époque et s'il ya un moment où c'était
au moment où le groupe a commencé à
éclater dans les années 80 c'était un
peu triste supposé vous cette rentrée
gros tu prendras un pain et quelques uns
retire le bouchon et puis tout taux sont
restés seuls sentiments
on savait ce qui se passait on sait pas
pourquoi
jazz
[Musique]
m
alors comme votre plus grand tube c2mi
flex on va faire une interview rifle
[Musique]
interview votre premier réflexe après
avoir fait l'amour ça ne servait votre
premier réflexe quand vous vous
réveillez le matin je regarde pour ce
brouch votre premier réflexe quand vous
rentrez dans une boîte à gants
je me planque dans ce cas je le présente
au dj votre premier réflexe quand une
fille repousse vos avances d'une
expérience en la matière votre premier
réflexe quand vous montez sur scène je
crache votre premier réflexe quand vous
arrivez dans une partouze ça c'est
comment reconnaître une chose pareille
j'aimerais bien avoir une telle réponse
mais j'ai jamais assisté à une partouze
de baby on aime bien et vous savez pour
ça que parce que depuis romain angie
dans ton froc l'énergie la tempe
votre premier réflexe quand vous toucher
un gros chèque
votre premier réflexe quand on vous
proposait la drogue il suffit de dire
ben il est là votre premier réflexe
quand on vous dit que votre dernier
album est le meilleur c'est dans une
conversation vraiment très
gauthier cas personnes qui souffrent pas
et ne souhaite accueillir à l'émoi de
votre piste favori par exemple d'uranium
il s'appelle astronautes et le morceau
richardson sunrise
alors y est contente ah oui c'est
formidable
ouais ah oui oui moi je trouve que
c'était une tellement bonne idée la
seule chose dont je suis resté perplexe
et pourquoi ils 900 euros parce que
c'était une charité ou quoi ça me donne
cette histoire si ça et moi ce que je
peux dire c'est que nous en tout cas
les billets sont pas feints relevant pas
à ce prix là alors peut-être que ça
faisait partie d'un plaquage d'un deal
vous paye le train l'hôtel la place à
duran du rhône pour 900 enfin comme si
vous habitez en australie a payé l'avion
jusqu'en dossier jusqu'en angleterre ça
fait ça fait assécher ensuite à 900
euros comme des changes est content de
les avoir rencontrés à participer aux
essais c'est un club d'élite seignosse
où on est on est dans la cour des grands
ici merci beaucoup à tous les cas merci
à lui
bordeaux
[Applaudissements]
oh
qui
là elle
[Musique]
c'est
salut la compagnie ainsi qu'à
[Musique]
les deux mecs ils ont embarqué arielle
dombasle tu veux j'accueille m'attend
brigitte feu c'est pierre bénichou
un fois brigitte fossey quart des
missions vous arrivez donc du théâtre de
la renaissance vous avez joué grosse
chaleur
la nouvelle pièce de notre ami laurent
qui est mise en scène par patrice
leconte
ça s'est passé comment très bien le
public est content d'en parler ça marche
bien parce que j'ai vu un reportage
jeudi soir sur france 2 où on voyait les
gens ont applaudi enfin formidable alors
aujourd'hui on appréhendait un peu parce
que on a toujours un petit coup de mou
le jour de la deuxième
et le public était vraiment au
rendez-vous et c'était formidable
presque aussi bien que le 1er juin -
c'était un public payant 1909 100 euros
la place
on n'y a pas de raison qu'on fasse payer
moins cher que bureau en bureau
quel effet ça fait brigitte d'avoir deux
débutants avec vous c'est à dire patrice
leconte qui n'a jamais fait de mise en
scène de théâtre et bénichou mais
écoutez en fait ce qui est
extraordinaire dans cette histoire c'est
que tous les professionnels catherine
arditi avec qui j'ai déjà travaillé
quatre soit amical anne benoît petit
jean qui est acteur professionnel bas
que ce soit qu'il ait très peu travaillé
jean benguigui si vous voulez c'est nous
qui avons le trac pour lui mais parce
que lui il a il a le cadeau de la
première fois il a une espèce
d'authenticité extraordinaires ont fini
par nous nous remettre en question en
tant que professionnel aux yeux non on
n'a pas c'est à plomb n'a pas ce côté là
filer des complexes
exactement c'était mon choix s'est alors
les dérives il générosité dans la
commentaires qui n'égale que celle
qu'elle a eu dans le pendant les
répétitions
j'ai conseillé au public d'y aller dans
les dix premières parce que quand il va
se rendre compte qu'il est acteur il va
commencer à se regarder jouer ça va être
une catastrophe à l'isie maintenant
alors pierre bénichou vous êtes il
venait de l'observateur depuis de
nombreuses années vous êtes même
directeur délégué vous êtes une vedette
dans les dîners en ville vous êtes le
meilleur invités de paris j'en ai été
témoin et maintenant vous êtes une
vedette sur scène alors est ce qu'on
peut parler de ta soeur un peu
en fait en fait c'est assez naturel de
l'avoir choisi laurent parce que si une
vedette dans la vie s'ils veulent être
sur les planches quoi l envie de voir
sur les planches évident il fait
tellement rire un radio tellement rien à
la télévision où j'avais envie qu'il
fasse rire le public parce que quand il
fait journaliste qui me fait marrer
vous savez le thème je sais le texte oui
papa pas tout ouais seulement ce que je
dis moi oui parce que j'ai cru qu'il
fallait tout apprendre
ah oui c'est pour ça que je me suis
noyée au début maintenant je sais qu'il
faut seulement bien ce qu'avait il faut
savoir aussi quand c'est à vous de
parler donc il vaut mieux apprendre le
texte
c'est vraiment la base le début c'est
bien alors écoutez vous avez remarqué
qu'on est toujours écoutée maintenant
c'est le sait c'est l'ère chiraquienne
écoutez écoutez je vais vous dire pour
moi c'est un truc formidable ce qu'on
vous dit j'ai beaucoup fait le clown
avec mes copains non je me suis dit un
jour je vais quand même monter sur les
planches de voir ce que c'est eh ben
c'est pas terrible
j'étais pourtant content de faire
pourquoi quand un team qui aime bien
conduit un qui a 85 ans villas d'une
formule 1 voyez les dégâts qu'ils
pouvaient alors à faire un concours de
promo brigitte pourquoi est ce qu'il
faut aller voir cette pièce il faut
aller la voir parce qu'elle est drôle et
parce que les gens se marrent mais cc
c'est vraiment merveilleux et alors moi
j'ai vécu des
c'est à sarthois aussi j'ai eu des
angoisses pendant tout pendant toutes
les répétitions parce qu'on n'y a pas de
public je me disais mais est ce que
c'est vraiment drôle et puis quand tout
à coup le public arrive alors là c'est
le cadeau mais là c'est vous et là tu as
envie de la moi ça a été une découverte
aussi qui avait pas de public pendant
les répétitions à vous ma carrière avoue
maintenant pour une raison est ce qu'il
faut aller voir cette pièce il faut
alors il faut y aller parce que ces
barres en quoi c'est marrant pire plus
c'est une pièce qui est à double entrée
c'est à dire que c'est en même temps une
pochade et en même temps une satire
sociale
j'adorais 7,7 cette histoire parce que
c'est un mec qui a des principes
c'est un psychorigide et j'ai toujours
pensé que les gens qui avaient des
principes pour des petites choses se
conduisait comme développe dès qu'ils
étaient confrontés une grande chose
or là c'est un mec qui fait chier toute
sa famille ont fait pas si on fait pas
ça on se lève à telle heure on fait
comme ça et le jour où on lui annonce
que sa mère vient de mourir
1 voyez là il est perdu il est foutu et
j'aime bien jouer les hommes perdent a
perdu mais très entouré quand même merci
beaucoup à celle des brocheurs de
laurent ruquier mise en scène de patrice
leconte c'est au théâtre de la
renaissance
oh
maintenant on va faire une interview qui
est cuit alors ruquier vous répondez à
la place de fossés d'accord fossé vous
répondez à la place de bénichou et
bénichou vous répondez à la place de
ruquier
et moi je vais faire la vaisselle
évidemment que je suis brigitte fossey
ses statuts et brigitte fossey moi je
suis laurent qu'est toi tu es laurent ok
oui pourquoi il faut cesser bénichou
d'accord ah oui c'est vraiment très
difficile c'était très compliqué déjà
moi j'ai du mal à comprendre la règle du
jeu donc je sais pas comment vous allez
arriver à répondre interview qui est qui
mais si vous aimez vous aimez toujours
les hommes brigitte a évidemment est
particulièrement pierre bénichou avec
qui je suis ravi de jouer et jean
benguigui qui peut-être j'ai une petite
aventure mais vous le saurez en niveau
en venant voir la pièce qu'est ce qui
vous plaît chez laurent ruquier brigitte
à part ses lunettes là d'un riz est
intelligent drôle beau n'osaient pas
passer brigitte fossey pour une
andouille
alors pierre tu es toujours pieds noirs
comme la base auront 10 et coup j'aime
bien prendre l'accent toews en temps
mais pas tous
c'est pas facile a dit à l'angop pierre
depuis quand vous perdez vos cheveux
écoutez c'est un charme supplémentaire
et de toute façon elle tombe tout candin
est d'accord pierre vous la trouvez
bonne visite
enfin je veux dire comme comédienne à
mon contact et s'améliorent chaque jour
parce que ma virilité lui donne plus de
féminité pas bien tu as bien noté un
nombre toujours pas festive
vous verrez
glock de la vie non plus six pourquoi
est ce qu'il est pas dans la pièce
steevy laurent haut parce que je se
tourner mon équipe
le rencontrer convaincu le compte de
mettre la pièce en scène et ben c'est
grâce à bénichou et si c'est bizarre son
truc et je comprends plus là je suis un
peu paumé lui s'est brisé je sais moi je
suis brigitte fossey embrassez-vous
[Musique]
non
je reçois maintenant aux rebelles de
chômeurs et fred et vincent desagnat
à
soit
[Applaudissements]
à
cassez vous casse et on s'est menti à
l'heure
les chansons n'ont finalement j'ai
aucune envie de les voir pas vous passer
jackal maintenant commence pas parce que
je vais le faire dix fois
quand on veut être comédien on articule
il a joué deux fois
il est comédien bien j'accueille masta
armelle deutsch omar et fred et vincent
desagnat
à
à 90 ans a très bien alors c'est bon tu
sais on dénote déménagement se faire
dedans mantha ramener aux cataractes en
piratant des beauvières qu'est ce qui
est bien chez moi ça ouais ouais ouais
ouais
oh que c'est gentil c'est très entier tu
pars le coeur
qu'est ce qu'il ya dans notre j'aime
bien ça il ya une petite poupée vaudou
pour toi ouais vous s'avère que dell de
la poupe est bien sûr il ya un string
mangeable a très bien merci
brison ya ça je sais pas pourquoi
excuse moi c'est pas du papier à rouler
mais [ __ ] ils sont pas venus les mains
vides il ya les bagnoles 2 laurent
ruquier je suis sûr il ya d'autres très
fière car cela oui gaza ah ouais ça je
connais j'arrivais déjà celle là je les
ai mais bon j'étais alors c'est tout
dans ce carton mais je crois que j'ai un
je crois que j'ai un autre canton c'est
un truc que j'ai retrouvé derrière une
une étagère l'autre jouait ce qu'on peut
m'amener l'autre carton pour thierry
plus rien
moi
s
saba
pour la femme est elle obligée de partir
alors
[Musique]
votre film votre film c'est le meilleur
film que j'aie jamais vu le carton
d'accord et on va commencer par armelle
parce qu'on se connaît pas non ça ne
donne rien à voir avec lorànt deutsch et
mama c'est son fils vous ai laissé mon
fils vous avez décidé de faire du
théâtre à l'âge de 12 ans d'abord vous
rentrez dans une troupe adolescente à
marseille c'est ta vie que je raconte
thierry la montée à paris cours florent
pas facile beaucoup de courage la
vocation chevillée au corps vous trouvez
un agent wii qui est une seconde maman
pour vous 3 1 cuil que la première
heureusement d'ailleurs que la première
étape
la première étape c'est cet avis que je
raconte
et puis là c'est parti un jour tu te
retrouves dans les caméras de patrick
sabatier en train de faire marilyn
monroe hawaï et ça a duré 20 minutes en
suisse ainsi qu'aux multivers tu as
essayé tout puis finalement tu l'as pas
fait tu trouvé ça ridicule de faire mal
aux rochers sabatier mon avis tu avais
raison
ensuite on te voit dans le placard ou
tuer la secrétaire de michèle laroque
c'est là que depardieu sur le tournage
de men main au cul mais tu te défend
très bien très très bien tu remets les
choses tout de suite au clair et après
tu as parlé comme il faut voilà ensuite
la boîte de zidi et là tu t'aperçois
finalement les réalisateurs sont pas
tous les mêmes parce que j'y dis
finalement n'attache pas une énorme
importance au dialogue est pour toi les
dialogues c'est pas un détail
ensuite tu fais laisse mes mains sur tes
hanches le chantal lauby nos amis les
flics de bob swaim qui voit là non bref
à ce que je voulais dire simplement
c'est que tu es la nouvelle fille drôle
et sexy du cinéma français pourquoi pas
bah oui non mais c'est sûr et j'espère
que c'est un bon positionnement bien la
passer un contenu c'est bien c'est bien
vincent desagnat bonjour bonsoir donc ex
de la bande à michaël youn et c'est pas
fini
meiway explorer pour pour ce projet à
ses côtés dans la beuze dans les 11
commandements et dans les bratisla boys
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir donc d'abord canal ses
parts et canal+ vous avez fréquenté
gaccio j'imagine canada l'an quel talent
ce grand bonhomme grand homme bien et
grands penseurs maintenant parce qu il
fait des vivres avec bilger est menacé
on sait pas c'est facile je les écoute
penser alors aujourd'hui un one man show
qui reprend le 12 octobre théâtre ce
show na waie
oui je chaussais dans le one man il fait
même il fait chaud c'est le début du one
man ça non c'est un autre truc sur ce
qu'il fait chaud et toi tu as la version
rien à voir vous êtes tous ici pour un
film qui s'appelle voilà un film de
charles nemes la comédie qui déménage
puisque c'est l'histoire d'un mec pas de
bouder la raconte et qui va raconter le
pitch normal ah oui pas mal c'est qu'on
s'y colle c'est l'histoire d'un mec qui
doit déménager demain sauf que demain
c'est aujourd'hui
voire même et voilà et donc évidemment
il a plein dans merde on m'a dit de
problèmes mais on va voir à quoi ça
ressemble c'est ce que je vais faire
tous les quatre j'ai regardé votre
caméra c'est le cas le rouge
et vous allez d'ailleurs magnéto serge
comme andy garcia à 2,3 à 3 2 3 je suis
dans la merde mais je déménage pour cet
outil de menacer aujourd'hui a souri à
temps à perdre
rodier sa filiale réserve en l'état des
lieux s'est accaparée par tonne bah oui
je perds tout l'argent la caution rien
de tout de lorenzo mazamet pour le
camionnette il tape un peu des cartons
de constance pour les goudrons
j'ai commencé avec des sacs de temps à
des cartons voilà un mari n'a guère nos
frères voilà mais vous allez board est
bien là comme ça un gros déménagement ça
se passe toujours avec des bières c'est
les bases c'est lorenzo a plongé bien
ton message pour la camionnette à celui
qui fait chier toute la rue là tu vas
minutes
c'est pas lui mr jobs espèce de bouffon
on attend la voiture ici faire des
photos avec un mannequin et c'est très
tendance et appart vide
c'est pour ça que c'est le monde si
c'est clim si antoine bien sûr que c'est
clean à temps et à la coi pour cinq
minutes on va ranger
vas-y fais comme chez toi ma poule john
vient l'emploi yens jeu c'est chaud pour
enfin s'en vient de me dire c'est la
polonaise qui vient faire cette photo
bonjour je sais la fille du propriétaire
est les patrons c'est la tâche que
j'espère c'est si les pc voilà le carton
le charme et metz avec tous les gens qui
sont là plaisir et djamel bouras aimé du
chéné catherine benguigui
ces signatures à dire que c'était une
pièce de théâtre du bic a fait un carton
caressant tranquille spéculateurs c'est
bien alors la suite est à l'étude
il va y avoir bientôt le carton 2,4
directement directeur avec stallone
voilà avec un ton
[Musique]
vous n'échapperez pas aux questions qui
tuent vincent ça fait longtemps qu'on
n'a pas vu le cul de michael youn
comment il va de 3 vous tombe ça vous
embête pas vincent que le cul de michaël
youn soit plus connue que votre tête
notre force ça ne s'arrange pas du tout
ça te fait rire mais vous n'avez pas
peur d'un cent quinze jours en mains
carrées et vous disons vous tapant sur
l'épaule comme ça ça va les conneries
maintenant foire était forain de
l'argent ça m'est arrivé hier soir
ah ouais donc voilà non ça ne dérange
pas armelle qui t'apprend le nom d'un
acteur déjà connu pourquoi pas gabin et
ventura pourquoi j'ai beaucoup hésité
seul problème c'est que mon père
s'appelait dutch high donc décevoir non
ouais et vous n'avez pas peur que en
vous appelant deutsch le film
l'américain nuisent à votre carrière
je pense que ça va légèrement le
compromettre mais j'invite tous les gens
à y aller quand même quand même pour
goma omar et fred
c'est comme la dernière fois c'est à
dire toi tu es le noir c'est toujours au
marc de maar pour le cinéma vous savez
qu'un français sur deux n'est même pas
les noirs chez vous c'est lequel
c'est lui d'accord ça s'est passé
naturellement vous avez vraiment choisi
d'être leblanc dans le dans le duo non
début j'étais homosexuel à dakar
finalement je suis devenu le blanc ou
bidons pourquoi bruno salomone ne fait
pas la promo avec vous vous allez à la
soirée en avant première une soirée pour
bien se goinfrer de quiche lorraine
nous n'avançons du cargo
ils sont
poutine
vincent mais je voulais ses pulls et
parce que parce que vous êtes ensemble
qu'on peut le dire ça oui mais on a
cassé hier et on a repris enfin pour sa
entendre parce que moi j'étais avec le
producteur avant non pas un micmac tu te
souviens toi et voilà c'est ça donc de
larmes natalie dionne dont tu es bon tu
veux qu'ils délaissent à vapeur
[Musique]
à
jambes
j'avais demandé à mes lignes de m'amener
un truc spécial pour vous et alors que
c'est bien moi que je laime
pour moi c'est comme les enfants
et oui allait bien aller la wii allait
bien aller bien elle est vraiment bien
j'ai même pas tu vois il ya un invité
qui doit venir après j'ai même pas envie
de j'ai même pas un n'a pas envie de
l'inviter autant si le patron de vanity
fair je devrais le l'invité mais bon je
vais alors les gars les plus sûres je
sais pas moi j'ai peut-être partir alors
maintenant j'accueille graydon carter
[Musique]
ça
non
john carter bonsoir bonsoir
pourquoi vous faire appeler graydon
alors que votre vrai nom et edward
cullen où mon père c'était elliott et
donc comme à pékin pour ne pas me
prendre
c'est tout mais ces vieux danser mais
c'est graydon c'est un vrai prénom c'est
à ça existe oui c'est vrai prénom c'est
un aux familles en fête qui était d'apt
et alors je vous présente notre ami
graydon carter si vous voulez bien il
est né le 14 juillet 1949 à toronto mais
vous avez choisi la nationalité
américaine
vous avez travaillé à time a life vous
avez créé spy vous allez travailler au
niveau observeur et last but not least
vous dirigez depuis 1992 la rédaction du
mensuel américain vanity fair qui est
lui dans le monde par 7 millions de
personnes et qui je crois on peut le
dire l'un des meilleurs jours nous 12 7
millions de lecteurs dans vendeur ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que c'est très
très bien payé la presse jean c'est
comme il gagne le mec non c'est chaud
chaque année il gagne un million et demi
de dollars la moitié de ce qu'on gagne
des ponceaux rien en coiffeur
rien pas la coiffure lauréat de nombreux
prix journalistiques en france et vous
avez également produit le film des
frères naudet sur le 11 septembre
l'attentât contre le world trade center
et aujourd'hui vous publié chez grasset
un livre qui s'appelle ce que nous avons
perdu voilà alors le pitch c'est
l'honneur perdu de l'amérique
la régression sous bush de la plus
grande démocratie du monde
alors vous entamez le bouquin avec une
hypothèse passionnante c'est que la
guerre en irak sur la guerre contre un
pays qui n'est ni un ennemi ni une
menace
en fait c'est un leurre dites vous un
leurre pour détourner l'attention du
peuple américain de la politique
intérieure c'est à dire que tout ça a
été fait pour permettre aux
néoconservateurs de reprendre le pouvoir
à l'intérieur le pouvoir idéologique
l'administration a effectivement été
très astucieuse elle s'est servi de
cette guerre contre l'irak comme
effectivement d'un leurre pour faire
oublier aux américains les problèmes
intérieurs
et pendant ce temps là effectivement le
pays était manipulé vers l'extrême
droite parce que en fait mouche n'a pas
été et n'est pas été élu comme homme
d'extrême droite comme un homme du
centre ce qui s'est passé au cours des
dernières années c'est que le visage la
démocratie américaine a complètement
changé
alors vous dites que la véritable guerre
est idéologique c'est celle qui a été
engagée par l'administration bush qui
vise à démanteler les avancées sociales
des dernières décennies ce qui s'est
passé c'est qu'on a lutté contre les
soviétiques pendant la guerre froide
pendant 50 ans mais c'était un
affrontement entre des super puissances
qui avaient les moyens de détruire la
planète
la planète des dizaines de fois aux
mélèzes américain pendant ce temps là
pendant la guerre froide ne jamais
abandonner des libertés civiles n'ont
pas n'ont pas
contrarié leurs alliés et comme nous
l'avons fait en quelques années alors
vous dites
espérons que cette période que nous
traversons ne soit pas le début d'une
nouvelle ère c'est vrai que ça fait
réfléchir tout ce qui se passe depuis
2001 on peut penser que ça peut
s'arrêter là au mois de novembre mais ça
peut aussi être le début d'une période
de dix ou vingt ans de régression
american civic et c'est à dire que
l'administration actuelle parle de
d'envahir maintenant l'iran après l'irak
pour mener une guerre sur trois fronts
au moyen-orient en afghanistan en irak l
iran un cette espèce de triple guerre
serait en tout cas irréparable 1 pour
l'autorité et la réputation des
etats-unis à travers le monde mais
surtout mais surtout nous n'avons que
deux soldats aux états unis on va se
retrouver avec à nouveau une grosse
cription obligatoires ce qui m'épate
c'est que dès qu'il ya un américain en
france il est toujours anti bush
ça veut dire que ceux qui savent écrire
des livres ils sont contre bouche de
tous pourquoi c'est que moi je crois que
nous on en reparle de ça aussi dans la
liberté d'expression je pense que les 50
% de personnes qui pensent voter bouche
encore aujourd'hui sont juste pas
informé de ce qu'il a fait
le savent toujours pas c'est pour ça que
il peut encore repasser
et moi j'avais à peu près tout ce qui se
publie en france d'américains et
critique en bouche et je suis moi même
très critique sur bush mais je trouve
qu'il ya quand même quelque chose qui me
gêne c'est que on lui prête des
ambitions et des et des projets qui sont
qui le dépasse à savoir que il a voulu
vous c'est votre votre thèse qu'il a
voulu pour pouvoir serrer la vis à
l'intérieur faire cette guerre dos dit
c'est parce que il veut rétablir parce
qu'il est membre d'une secte
moi je crois que tous ces hommes
politiques ont très peu de marge de
manoeuvre
non ce qui s'est passé c'est que le 11
septembre a été pour les états unis
comme la défaite de 40 pour l'extrême
droite française c'est une divine
surprise on perd la guerre en 40
ça permet de mettre pétain à la tête du
pays et l'extrême droite est contente et
ce qui s'est passé le 11 septembre c'est
la naissance aux états unis d'une
présidence impériale d'une dictature et
lui c'est ce que vous dites et la divine
surprise c'était le 11 septembre et
grâce au 11 septembre
ils ont plus m grâce à vous alimenter
l'anti france qui existent en amérique
ans je m'en fous c'est pas comme ça que
ça se passera bien
alors donc vous passez en revue graydon
carter toutes les guerres de bush
effectivement la guerre contre le
terrorisme ils attaquent l'irak plutôt
que d'attaquer l'arabie saoudite parce
que dites-vous ce sont ses amis et ça
aussi ça a été racontée dans un certain
nombre de livres les liens entre la
famille bush et l'arabie saoudite
vous parlez de l'afghanistan où le
mollah omar contrôler un tiers du pays
et vous dites que l'afghanistan
aujourd'hui est devenu est redevenu le
premier producteur mondial d'opium mais
le plus étonnant dans votre bouquin
c'est pas ça c'est la gabegie
qui règne au niveau du budget des armées
c'est un truc inimaginable c'est à dire
que le budget de la défense désunie il
est de 500 milliards de dollars par an
500 milliards de dollars par an et
pourtant après sept mois de guerre
il ya toujours des soldats qui n'ont pas
de gilet pare balles et les parents des
soldats sont obligés de surfer sur
internet pour acheter à 15 100 dollars
des gilets intercepteurs des gilets
pare-balles quoi c'est une véritable
tragédie
c'est à dire que moins de la moitié des
soldats sont équipés effectivement de
gilets pare-balles en tout cas qui
puisse résister aux aubades larmes la
plus répandue et puis l'autre moitié des
soldats ont ddd gilet pare-balles de des
piètres qualités et lens qui se déplace
en revanchard y a que la moitié des
chars il a plus d'un an après le début
de la guerre il y a que la moitié déjà
qu'ils sont effectivement blindés et
l'autre de l'autre moitié n'est pas
l'autre moitié des chat n'est pas là des
scuds ou les blessures abominable qu'on
a jamais vu par le passé c'est à dire
que vous avez organisé du monde à savoir
ça ne va pas ça nous disait c'est un
pays du tiers-monde n'oubliez pas moi
j'ai vu ça va me dire le débarquement
américain 42 rocard arriver
vous savez à quel point un à quel point
c'était désorganisé quel point un jour
il ya eu un container forme a raconté
aux enfants un container énorme qui est
un verbe cru qu'on avait de la
nourriture pour tout le monde c'était
uniquement du papier de chiottes s'était
trompé dans les détruire
il ya aussi le recours par l'armée aux
entreprises privées
c'est à dire qu en irak il ya plus
d'américains
le soldat américain employés par des
entreprises privées que deux soldats
britanniques
c'est aussi cette privatisation de la
guerre c'est quelque chose de très
nouveau et de très inquiétant la
proportion encore plus importante je
crois qu'il ya 20 à 25 mille soldats
supplémentaires qui travaille pour
halliburton et d'autres grosses sociétés
américaines évidemment quand ces soldats
sont sûrs on n'en parle pas dans les
statistiques on ne parle que des livres
est sold out et réserviste mais il ya
des centaines de ses soldats qui
travaille pour le privé qui sont
effectivement deux anonymes et et le
pire évidemment c'est que cette guerre a
fait passer à une loi qui s'appelle
patriot act qui a été voté vous dites au
moment de la psychose de l'anthrax à
l'époque où les députés ne pouvaient pas
accéder à leurs bureaux donc ça a été un
petit peu à la sauvette en est on est
vraiment dans cette dans cette idée de
40 en france
effectivement on bouge ses services de
ce facteur psychose et angoisse pour
effectivement faire passer en vrac
ces lois qui battait en brèche tous les
acquis sociaux
ceci ces lois ont été votées pendant la
nuit promulguée toujours lent au
lendemain parce que effectivement les
américains avaient peur hélas a fait
régresser d'une vingtaine d'années les
états unis et on veut maintenant serrer
encore plus la guerre menée au
moyen-orient est là pour amener des
libertés
chez soi en fait c'est pas vrai dire
thierry grèce c'est ce qui vous permet
de parler de dictature élus de
présidence impériale c'est à dire que
vous pensez que depuis le 11 septembre
la société américaine a changé de nature
non anna mentalement il semble que le
caractère américain à caractère généreux
c'est un caractère plein d'espoir et je
crois qu'il ya beaucoup d'intelligence
beaucoup de gentillesse mais ils soient
un petit peu aveugle et un par
l'angoissé d'une année d'un attentat
terroriste et les décisions soient
prises sur ces bases là plutôt que de se
fonder sur des questions plus
importantes
brydon avant de partir un pronostic
bouche kerry s'est posé une question de
sexe non il me semble que la campagne de
bush était très bien mené prodan
probablement la meilleure depuis
cinquante années et ce sera un modèle de
campagne électorale pour les années à
venir et saufs c'est un immense
changement du côté de kyriba c'est bush
qui va l'emporter
c'est une bonne nouvelle c'est que ça
durera que quatre ans et après pourra
pas se représenter c'est la seule bonne
nouvelle
daniel adam
oui mais ensuite à 4 ans vous aurez à
radom charge par thomas guerry et elton
julian il se sera lente à travers
obama
ce que nous avons perdu c'est éviter
chez grasset
messieurs
[Musique]
tu
j'accueille maintenant stéphane freiss
voilà d'ailleurs pratiquement que des
gens de théâtre ce soir avec nous il ya
comment ça va nous arriver du théâtre
mais oui je sors de scène
voilà comme comme nos amis voilà c'est
un endroit où on passe en sortant du
théâtre
voilà c'est sympa de faire celui barbie
de nuit les rendez-vous de christian
marc gautheron fait chier tout le monde
voilà ça s'est bien passé ça va ça s'est
très bien passé mais je suis pas bon
signe si ça se passe bien pour lui il va
nous prendre du bon donc vous êtes
comédie des champs elysées où vous jouez
brooklyn boys
voilà il ya eu dernièrement 5 x 2 de
françois ozon
il ya le grand rôle de steve suissa qui
sort le 13 octobre
vous êtes au top là non vous êtes au tac
fort mais ça a été long pour vous parce
que vous êtes un lent oui mais c'est à
dire qu'on va dire que depuis dix ans
j'ai pas déranger beaucoup de monde donc
il est à peu près temps que j'arrive à
maturité voilà doucement ça se fait mais
ça commence à bien marcher alors oui je
vais pas me plaindre au top son métier à
l'insu du public public savait qui sort
du bois
non mais c'est vrai que c'est un lent
stéphane vous avez une rébellion tardive
1 j'ai eu une rébellion d'âge et j'ai
pris mon temps
ouais bah l'a longuement cette année je
regrette pas parce que je me dis
qu'aujourd'hui je me sens je ne sais pas
qu'est ce qui s'est passé mais si vous
avez vous n'arriviez pas à devenir un
homme voulait rester un film à retirer
du marché
roger vous empêche pas de faire mieux
nancy passion quand voilà mai mais oui
mais je me disais qu'il était peut-être
il filme fallait un certain temps pour
elle vous en a fallu du temps il m'a
fallu mais je suis passé par le théâtre
j'ai rencontré des gens que j'aime et
j'ai compris que j'avais envie de jouer
un certain rôle et pas d'autres c'est
pas vraiment un l'ange g
j'ai été vraiment à la rencontre de moi
même et les gens avec qui j'ai travaillé
parce que ce que je souhaite c'est à
dire quinze ans quand même oui mais
justement c'était il ya dix sept ans
mais menez c'est sais plus qui disait je
suis rentré en moi même j'en suis sorti
j'étais dégoûté j'en suis très très
vigilent ferait pas qu'il est très
bosselée point de presse qu il est très
bon on savait que je vais venir ce soir
il ressemble à une très grande peinture
qui se trouve à florence et qui
s'appelle l'homme aux yeux gris et je ne
sais plus qui a causé ces travaux
c'est pas mais je m'explique j'ai un
week-end de libre que je fonce alors
soyez au top était beau comme un tableau
qui a faim
c'est faut faire attention oui enfin
chantal je savais pas que sera accueilli
comme ça ça fait très beau pourquoi en
chemin merci bien alors ce soir dont
vous étiez au théâtre dans brooklyn boys
de donald margut liste mise en scène de
michel fagadau alors le pitch voulait le
faire mais je le fais mais je crois que
vous êtes très forts pour ça
non j'ai pas très fort mais bon alors
c'est un écrivain qui publie un livre de
souvenirs de jeunesse et qui se retrouve
face à sa famille face à un leader un
livre qui devient un best-seller voilà
qu'il ya un peu écrit écrit voter en
ayant peu de succès mais certainement
également des choses intéressantes que
parce qu'on a lues voilà et voilà qu'il
écrit le best-seller inspiré de son
autobiographie romancée et il revient
pour la livrer à ceux qu'ils aiment dans
ce brooklyn qu'il a quitté quand il
était jeune à son père son père lui
reproche de ne pas avoir repris le
magasin de chaussures son grand pote lui
reproche de pas assez fréquenté la la
synagogue et il se rend compte
finalement que son succès lui amène de
l'amertume et de la solitude
voilà c'est un peu c'est une jolie
métaphore entre la rencontre fait le
succès n'arrive jamais exactement quand
on les met à faire mais c'est aussi une
pièce qui parle de la et de
l'incommunicabilité et de la tolérance
et je trouve que c'est un sujet que moi
me touche particulièrement ce moment
donc voilà pourquoi j'ai 600 le haut
c'est si tu as comme la ronde que vous
avez joué deux fois mais c'est une c'est
une ça ressemble à la rendre sauf que
dans la ronde chaque les chaque deux
scènes les personnages changent alors
que là je passe d'un personnage à
l'autre et je je mais si vous êtes
vraiment au top parce que notre promo ou
encore le grand rôle de steve suissa
avec bérénice bejo françois berléand
lionel abelanski rufus peter kiotis et
bien le pitch réplique à jodie a
peut-être que c'est comme ça l'accueil
otc l'animal oui mais je crois que tout
le monde l'appelle connaître haïti mais
c'est vrai ça ça lui a dit en anglais
oui vraiment je me dis que yacht pendant
qu'ils n'ont pas l'air mal
il avait passé aux coyotes donc le pitch
est mensonge d'amour là pour le coup
voilà un
alors ces cinq potes qui sont acteurs il
ya un grand réalisateur qui vient à
paris vous vous décrocher le rôle donc
des bâches mans comptant et puis vous
rentrez chez vous pour le dire à votre
épouse
elle vous annonce qu'elle est gravement
malade et pire que tout on vous annonce
aussi que le réalisateur en question le
grand réalisateur américain
finalement il vient de recevoir l'accord
d'un acteur américain qu'il en avait
parlé avant et donc mensonge d'amour
vous vous retrouvez en train de faire
croire à cette femme que vous allez
avoir le rôle que vous êtes venir un
très grand à leur manière de
l'accompagner de la mène de manière la
plus douce vers la vers la mort c'était
le plus beau mensonge qu'on puisse faire
c'est un mensonge qu'on fait par amour
c'est une bande de potes qui a galéré
qui est donc on va dire que je suis un
peu le leader parce que je suis et le
plus âgé celui qui a vraiment voulu
faire ce métier d'acteur et voilà
qu'elle va elle va mourir et ça va être
assez rapide et je lui fais ce mensonge
et donc on a on s'invente un tournage
fictif avec cette espèce de spielberg
que jupiter
il ya un côté il ya un côté un peu good
bye lenin dans cette idée de faire vivre
à quelqu un quelque chose qui n'est pas
vrai simplement pour que la personne
soit le sait c'est un beau film c'est
assez bien l'histoire avec cela vous
regardez votre caméra et vous dites
magnéto serge magnéto serge bravo
le réalisateur m'a tellement que l'aja a
laissé passer ça est en retard bonjour
monsieur le christ une baraque
bon
et si bien je crois c'est pour l'heure
c'est bon ça tu crois mais c'est bon
ces combats au couteau
[Musique]
c'est la jeunesse
j'ai très bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
tapez été pris pour le rôle je te
rappelle
et on addition tharoul
oui
[Applaudissements]
ces gens là tu lui as dit que tu avais
le roule tout à fait croire qu de chine
dac tangage elle sait pas que tu joues
pacha glock alors on va se débrouiller à
y voir que du feu
j'ai un pote maquettiste il va nous
faire des magazines avec des interviews
des photos besson a du débat dans
l'existant il ya un nombre de figurants
qui faisait les vénitiens star pression'
an dont 300 au creux de mon époux est qu
à vous que nous respirons d'être pareil
ne pas vous demander d'être complice
d'un manchon
le plan qui va est un qui sommeille en
toi le dis jamais jamais que cette image
de temps d'une seconde
court ou celui d'oran
le temps de parole
le grand roque personnes encore plus
filer à maurice il a joué pour sa femme
c'est plus grand rôle de sa vie je vois
que ça la rend heureuse de savoir que
les bus euros on a l'impression qu'elle
va mieux avec tout ce que je lui raconte
du tournoi avec ses presque est notre
invité ce soir
sortie le 13 octobre alors on va voir on
va vérifier l'état de votre popularité
stéphane freiss on va vous faire une
interview je suis au top
stéphane tom cruise va essayer de
déjeuner avec vous quand il est venu à
paris
il a essayé mais si vous croyez que j'ai
le temps ce moment vous avez numéro de
téléphone de nicole kidman bougeait pas
au top
amy acuff combien de filles on voulait
coucher avec vous ce mois ci
sérieusement vous être un tombeur non
pas du tout ah ben on a pas du tout
enfin c'est pas du tout
ça y est je vous ai dit de me servir de
mecs ont voulu coucher avec vous cette
semaine
moi c'est ça sert alors là il faut que
je trouve un pourquoi un à lui il veut
j'aurai un mec au top
luc besson a pris une demi-heure pour
vous écrire un film c'est vrai il vous
l'a dit ouais claude lelouch fait sa
supplique dans son nouveau film je garde
le sourire
vous iriez dans un film de claude
lelouch
ah oui est-ce que j'étais bon acteur ça
va c'était assez crédible fait la bise à
alain chabat maintenant qu'il est au top
changez musée
en salles le 13 octobre
on passe semble heineken woods
allah
un blind test spécial musique de film ce
soir j'ai besoin d'avoir le titre du
film
la sélection est faite parmi quelques
amis proches
[Musique]
j'ai beau hein qu'est ce qui me disait
dans le rail de dix mois la fille qui
était avec lui doit c'est ta soeur ou
non c'était ma copine à 10 ans elle est
bien aussi à eva écoute moi bien tu es
prêt et ben écoute toi un homme et une
femme
j'essaye attention numéro un
ça fait un gros
que stéphane fraize raddho
voilà un point pour l'équipe de ces
packs mathieu qui est vraiment comme ce
soir stéphane freiss déjà il est en tête
du leader bodyguard coin
oh
je rêvais
faisons le
dumas qu'une aussi on y créatrice en
trois matches c'est quoi quand j'ai vu
ce film j'ai pleuré à la fin quand il ya
des chansons qui montent dans l'avion là
j'adore nom lumière c'est le sabre oui
c'est quand il revoit le voile comme ça
le sabre hop ça se fait en deux j'ai
très envie de faire la même continuer le
concours
mickey
à
non
c'est quoi j'ai pleuré quand j'ai vu que
j'avais stéphane freiss au top
non mais on sait très entraînés avant
3-0 boire aux thèses rayhana foot ils
vont au cinéma toute la journée
alors séparé
ce qui change au rang
voilà c'était un point pour l'équipe de
long et qui est bras volant et
on continue michael chasse oui
évidemment
jeu de
solitaire
un peu cheap les serbes
thierry michael j non même pas
et gatti d'égalité jamais chacun chacun
donc ça fait quatre points pour stéphane
freiss et deux points pour l'équipe de
longues et on continue michael
ah ah
notre marque a droit à ses fins alors
qu'un bois il est au top ça fait combien
la paix st bravo continuez
[Applaudissements]
trois points pour l'équipe de l'euro et
qui est bravo laurent oui on continue
michael
[Musique]
c'est moi que jamais la divine alors
passionnant nous
négation quatre points quatre points
pour l'équipe de laurent ruquier
donc cela remonte
quatre à cinq rôles à la la ces choix là
non vous avez gagné le pari qui prévaut
stéphane freiss vous êtes au top
[Applaudissements]
la robe en même temps la revanche tous
les bons coups chacun pour sa gueule
attention michael way
fort enfin les gros fort c'est un autre
spectacle fait les excès ou ce spectacle
c'est un oui au théâtre du temple 18 rue
du faubourg de tombes 75011 paris
et ils soient à 21,1 moi je serais bien
passé moi j'y suis à 18h en général à
monaco et au progrès continus michael a
le film le vif subway philadelphia nom
vient du soufflage
elle a soufflé
alors
bien sûr mais en tient son stage ya plus
à perdre à serge est ce qui vient de
perdre son emploi
oui bah oui c'est ça oui il a écouté un
soufflage voilà donc c'est dommage ce
père serge parce qu'on voulait de faire
faire la captation du spectacle va aller
hop sera un autre either side tu effaces
fret voilà efface le rouge tout comme
maîtresse le et cela sans nous faire
efface le complètement quand on voit nos
mouvements efface tout voilà donc on est
à 0
là on recommence tout on est dans le
chacun pour sa gueule michael souffle
jha
j'adore attendant tu as une chance de
marquer le point dis moi le musicien qui
est toujours
j'habite à perdre et je peux même film
quoi je sais pas je me suis fait tuer sa
conjointe alors là on arrive dans cette
situation fait personne n'a rien
remarqué
donc celui qui va marquer ce point là
alors je vous demande vraiment de ne pas
souffler parce que celui qui va marquer
ce point là maintenant sera le roi de la
soirée ce sera vraiment lui là les
normes c'est un musicien c'est giorgio
moroder et alors et alors
et donc je vous demande vraiment de
souffler soyez gentils c'est très grave
michael
on entendra
la donne a donné s'est encore fait
remarquer soufflage et riche et ouais
comme l'a dit qui tu l'as dis toi moi
j'ai conseillé à monsieur là va donc
perdre balance pas est ce que c'est que
ce jeu où tout le monde triche je ne
sais pas alors maintenant
excuse moi je l'honneur excuse moi on
continue on va faire maintenant on va
continuer jusqu'à ce que quelqu'un qui
gagne six tirs au but
attention je veux l'interprète cette
fois mais voilà c'est le ba voila c'est
tout plat
d
oh
comment ça va l état corpus l'état
campus à guillaume durand comment ça va
fêter ses dix ans durant avait il de
tourner quand tu cela alors comment
c'était quand plus comment c'était et
fred très bien comment c'était campus
alors c'est excellent
rires tout moi et c'était une spéciale
françoise ses bras et vous l'avez
regrettez vous avez dit que c'était un
dommage qu'elle soit décédée
tout à fait ces diarrhées que ça a été
dire plusieurs reprises ses liens et
c'était tout à fait jouissif les
émissions sur des gens qui sont morts on
oublie de dire qu'on regrette qui selon
décédé quelques fois mais on est content
des fois oui ça arrive ouais vous étiez
en train de vous amuser au blind test
alors qu'il était en train de gagner à
ses brevets dans l'équipe des gagnants
moi mais là tu te mets là alors voilà et
tu vas me dire alors frédéric comme un
concert non non vous êtes vous est à la
ramasse
vous êtes au bout je suis le justicier
du blind test on va en faire un
portuaires ont fait ça tu vas me dire
qu'ils chantent alternance de joie
honoré bastel bandeau et l'ordre
non
ap ap les revoilà
voilà c'était tout le monde en parle
avec en uc et rauscher brésil s'est
terminée cette ligne
jean vélizy benoît petit jean cau
théâtre de la renaissance
arielle dombasle l'album s'appelle
damman
elle est en concert au bataclan les 25
ans
28 et 29 janvier 2005 bruno gaccio
traversy et des lipides gère les lignes
les magistrats chez flammarion
john surratt l'album sort le 11 octobre
astronautes voilà omar et fred vincent
desagnat armelle deutsch le carton de
charles nemes sortie le 6 octobre
omar et fred ont 4 le temple rue du clos
du temps dans le onzième round heures
tous les soirs à partir du 12 octobre
brydon carter ceux que nous avons perdus
chez grasset stéphane vrai au top
le grand le site suisse avec bérénice
béjo peter coyote y françois berléand le
13 octobre
mais aucune boy la comédie des champs
elysées voilà le fiji j'appelle michaël
canitrot méchant l'album s'appelle so
happy in tariff merci et bravo pour ta
fiancée
c'était tout le monde en parle
[Musique]
oui
oh
[Musique]
à
non
[Musique]
demain